cela passe par un dispositif nouveau
cette mesure de couvre feu sanitaire qui
entrera donc en vigueur vendredi
demain à minuit je vais vous en préciser
maintenant les modalités les territoires
d'abord soumis à ce couvre feu annoncé
par le chef de l'état hier soir son pari
et les sept autres départements d'île de
france
les métropoles de lyon lille toulouse
montpellier saint-etienne aix marseille
iii et grenoble
ce couvre-feu s'établira de 21h à 6h du
matin
cela signifie qu'à 21h chacun devra être
chez soi et que sauf exception tous les
lieux commerces ou services publics
recevant du public seront fermés ces
règles doivent bien entendu s'appliquer
avec bon sens comme pendant le
confinement certains déplacements
resteront autorisés pour des raisons de
santé pour aller à l'hôpital où aller
acheter des médicaments dans une
pharmacie de garde
par exemple pour des raisons
professionnelles si vous travaillez de
nuit ou que vos horaires de travail ne
vous permettent pas d'être chez vous à
21h
si vous avez un train ou un avion qui
arrive qui part après 21h il faudra le
cas échéant pouvoir montrer votre billet
si vous êtes contrôlés
si vous devez vous rendre auprès d'un
proche en situation de dépendance pour
sortir votre animal de compagnie près de
chez vous comme pendant la période de
confinement il faudra pour sortir après
21h vous munir d'une attestation
prouvant que vous répondez de l'une de
ces exceptions l'attestation et
l'ensemble des informations concernant
la situation sanitaire et des mesures
relatives au couvre-feu
sont disponibles sur le site du
gouvernement qui j'espère va s'afficher
ou en appelant le numéro vert 0 800 100
30 00 voilà vous avez les références du
site qui s'affiche à l'écran
de même certains établissements
échapperont naturellement à la fermeture
anticipée
il s'agit des établissements de santé et
médico-sociaux des structures d'accueil
des plus précaires les hôtels des
restaurants faisant la livraison à
domicile et des établissements publics
qui assure un service en soirée et la
nuit comme notamment les commissariats